[MUSIC PLAYING]
BEN BREEN: So my
name is Ben Breen.
We're just looking--
the Cloud's theme
have been all over my slides.
That cloud in the
corner was actually
an Android robot this morning.
And my job, I actually work
in Android, not Google Cloud.
So they've changed a few things.
But anyway, I know that
this is a Cloud conference.
But we thought we'd set
up shop here and run
a few sessions on Android, in
particular, Android Enterprise.
So, yeah, thank you.
Thank you for coming along.
Typically, we announce
Android-related things
at Google I/O, so there'll
be a lot more activity
in around one month's time.
So, yeah, I head up the
Android Enterprise engineering
division.
And we're actually
based out of London.
Android is actually
built in two locations.
Most of it's here
in Mountain View.
But there are also some
significant engineering teams
in London as well.
So today, we're going
to look at privacy.
I say pr-ih-vacy
because I'm British.
I tried switching
to pr-i-vacy but I
couldn't do it consistently.
So if you don't understand,
privacy equals privacy--
so how privacy can benefit
IT and employees, and some
of the unique
features we have in
Android that we've
introduced recently,
and also just to give you
a feeling for where Android
is going in the enterprise.
So as you know, privacy has
never been more important.
Not only has the legal
landscape changed,
with things like GDPR and
so on, but also people's
attitudes towards
technology and privacy
as technology plays a
increasingly important role
in people's lives.
So when we talk to
customers, we consistently
hear about this
tension between secure
and always-on and
private and the ability
to detach from work.
And this is exaggerated
in BYOD devices
where users have a greater
expectation of privacy.
And it's in this
tension that we felt
there is an
opportunity in Android
for IT to enable security whilst
also enabling employee privacy,
especially BYOD devices.
So you could ask, is
this just a problem
that the Valley has
and we're solving it
for other people in the Valley?
Is this some kind of
touchy-feely problem?
Or is there a real opportunity
in actually solving
the privacy problem?
When we're talking to customers,
privacy consent consistently
comes up as the number-one
reason why mobile deployments
hit friction, meaning
adoption of BYOD
isn't what companies expect.
And this is also
shown on the slide
here in the 2018 IDC survey.
Android actually
has a unique mode
to deal with this very issue.
And it's one of my favorite
features in Android.
So we'll come on
to that shortly.
So Android is helping companies
make mobility deployments
successful.
We want to change the dynamic
between employees and IT.
Employees should feel empowered
and not burdened by technology
with something that is simple,
secure, and respectful.
But we also want IT
to feel empowered,
to increase privacy and
well-being without compromising
on security by decoupling
these three concepts.
And so with some of
Android's unique offerings,
IT decision makers can actually
advocate for their employees.
So this is apparent dichotomy
between security and privacy.
Can these truly
be separated such
that having strong security
does not mean less privacy?
Well, let's take a look.
So this is the typical world
of enterprise technology.
Patch Tuesday marked
on the calendar
gives IT the best chance of
ensuring devices are secure,
and running virus scans, and
monitoring everything which
is happening on the
device continuously using,
typically, third-party software.
Security is actually
enabled through visibility.
IT needs to know about
everything happening
on the device in order to ensure
nothing insecure is happening.
Now, mobile is
increasingly shifting away
from this philosophy using
some emerging new security
capabilities.
Yet a lot of assumptions around
security through visibility
have carried on to mobile.
You know, OK, what's
the virus scanning
solution for mobile phones?
And how do I get visibility
into everything which
is happening on the device?
We don't think that
privacy needs to be
at the cost of great security.
We also don't believe device
ownership should determine
how secure a device can be.
There's no universal
law that says you can't
have a secure BYOD device.
It's simply down to how
we architect platforms.
Now, IT have a
challenging enough job
as it is enabling
business-use cases.
We don't want IT to have
to worry about plugging
gaps in the platform itself.
We also don't want
you to have to worry
about installing third-party
security solutions
and worrying about the patch
rate in a particular month
to ensure devices are secure.
So we're trying to make sure
that ownership, security,
and privacy can be
configured individually
without the need for a business
to go to another vendor.
So that all sounds nice, but
how do we make sure that--
how do we do this in practice?
Well, let's look at some of
the fundamental architecture
of Android.
So first of all, we have
server-side malware scanning,
so through Google
Play and Managed Play.
So Managed Play is a version of
Google Play which enterprises
can use to curate
their own app store
and even push out
apps onto devices,
update devices, and manage
their configuration.
So anything that comes through
Google Play or Managed Play,
first of all, will
be scanned there.
And then we've got
Google Play Protect
for device-side
scanning as well.
Now, Android is actually
built-- or it was originally
built on top of SELinux.
And one of the great
benefits of SELinux
is process isolation,
which means
that if something
insecure is happening
in one of these boxes, so
let's say one of these boxes
was a piece of malware or
somehow some malware got
injected, well, the blast
radius is more or less impacted
to the app itself and
not outside of that.
So this is kind of
process isolation.
So if a process
becomes compromised,
it can't gain access to the
space of another process.
And you can also interrogate
the operating system.
So you can ask it
questions like,
is the version of the
operating system that's
running on this device,
is it a official version?
And that would be
cryptographically tested
with a trusted boot using
a hardware root of trust.
So you can ask
questions like that.
You can ask simple
questions like,
is the password on
this device, does it
meet my criteria for strong?
Or has Google Play Protect
flagged any issues?
So two things fall out of this--
remarkably flexible management
and, for the first time,
the ability to remove conflict
between privacy and security.
So you don't need to
know what's going on
inside one of these
boxes necessarily
to know that the overall
device is secure.
But that might not be
enough to convince you.
Fair enough.
So let's look at
another feature.
And this is my favorite
feature in Android,
and it's used heavily
by Googlers but also
many other companies,
small and large,
so something called
Work Profile.
And the way that I kind
of explain this is it's
like having two phones
in one piece of hardware.
So on the right, you
can see on your screen,
you've got a Work tab.
And on the left, you've
got a Personal tab.
Everything that goes on in--
anything that goes on the
work side of your phone cannot
access the personal side.
And anything that happens in
the personal side cannot access
the work side.
So not only have you got
these kind of boundaries
between processes themselves,
which I talked about
on the previous
slide, but you've also
got this kind of almost
two virtual phones running
inside this phone.
And that separation is
enforced at the OS level, which
means that multiple
vulnerabilities would have
to be exploited for something
in a personal profile
to access anything
in the work profile--
both application sandboxing
and the OS security
boundary between
these two areas.
So in the traditional
world, this would've broken.
If you can't see
what's happening
on the personal side
of the phone, well,
how do you know whether
the device is secure?
Well, the kind of
Android stance on this
is it doesn't
matter because what
happens on the personal side
can't access the work side.
They're almost like
two separate phones.
And even from the work side,
you can ask the OS questions
about the overall security
stance of the device.
So you can ask it, are there
any insecure or untoward apps
on this phone anywhere?
And it will tell you
the answer to that
by looking in the
personal and work profile
without breaching the
trust of the user.
And then you can take action as
a result of that as well, which
is usually configured
to be automatic,
like wipe out the work profile.
And so you get these kind of
strong-level OS assurances
that the device is in a
good security posture,
meaning direct visibility is
not needed to ensure security.
Hence, whatever the user is
doing in their personal profile
remains private.
You can't look at
network logs or anything
like that from
the personal side.
And yet companies are
able to control and do
whatever they want within
the work side of the phone.
And if you really
wanted to put virus
scanning on there on the work
side, you absolutely could.
So IT only manages and views
apps in the work profile.
Personal data is
stored separately.
IT can erase the work
profile or apps and data.
It can't view or
erase personal data.
It's literally like having
two phones in one phone.
Now, if you're provisioning
a device on BYOD--
so let's say you bring
your own device to work.
The typical flow, the
thing that happens
is you enter your work
email address and password.
You add an account.
And if you've configured a
work profile, it will say,
either you have the option
to have a web profile
or you must have a web profile
depending on what you set.
The device will
then automatically
create that separate
space for you,
that separate web profile, that
separate phone within a phone.
So I think the takeaway
from this section
is you consider
enabling work profile,
especially for reasons of
privacy for your employees,
and you'll almost certainly find
that your BYO adoption goes up.
And so we believe this
is the modern approach
to mobile security, which
enables privacy and helps
eliminate the lack of certainty
which was often a deployment
blocker in a lot of places.
Employee confidence-- they
know that data belongs to them,
and they know what their
employer can and can't see.
And because these are
separate data stores,
if the employee leaves or
the account is compromised,
the work data can be wiped
without losing personal data.
So it reduces the risks
associated with personal data
loss.
And because it's clear what
is work and what is personal,
users don't have this kind of
scary, unknown question around
whether they're
allowed to be doing
certain things on the
device or being uncertain
about what the company may
or may not be able to see.
So think about the
atmosphere around user data
privacy, GDPR in the EU.
This is a chance for the
Android as a platform
to enable IT to align business
interests with employee
interests and an opportunity
for IT to get ahead
of emerging expectations
around this technology.
So we covered the
privacy/security trade-off.
But another trade-off
that we talked about,
this kind of a
double-edged sword
with always-on connectivity,
that promise that now you
can work from anywhere, this
kind of mobile workforce
being the mantra of
enterprise deployments.
Well, that's great until
it's time not to be working,
and everything is still
running on your device.
So let's look at
how we're trying
to separate the notion of
mobility and always-on.
We talked to a lot of
users, and the responses
have been amusing
and concerning.
So my phone is the first thing
I look at when I wake up.
I think probably a lot
of people in this room
can relate to that.
I certainly can.
If I don't respond
in 30 minutes,
people think I've died.
Actually, this is a true story.
So someone went
hiking for the day,
and didn't set their
out-of-office notification
on their calendar.
They didn't have
connectivity, and they
didn't respond to a
message within three hours.
And their colleagues
called the police
and reported him as
a missing person.
It's kind of
ridiculous, isn't it?
My phone has become a dictator.
So the device which is supposed
to be enabling us actually
becomes a ball and chain.
It's that double-edged sword
of connectivity and well-being.
So as a society, we
haven't caught up
with how to manage this.
And the tools haven't caught up
with human behavior, frankly.
Users don't have a way
to filter or mitigate
this always-on reality
we now live in.
Android is taking this
problem very seriously
and is starting to address it.
So we introduced the concept
of digital well-being
in Android in Google
I/O last spring.
And the kind of
concept behind this
is we don't want phone
ruining our lives.
They should be improving
lives and making workers
more productive, certainly
not distracting us
from the most important
things in life.
So we're starting to introduce
some features to advance this.
So I previously
introduced Work Profile.
Now, one of the benefits I
didn't talk about at the time
was, well, because there's
kind of essentially two
phones in one phone, you can
switch one of the phones off,
so you can switch
your work phone off.
And that means that everything
on there is gone, literally.
Nothing can drain your
battery in the background.
It can't sync.
There's no notifications
from any of your work apps.
And actually, I use this
feature all the time.
So late in the evening, I tend
to switch my work profile off.
And then when I wake up
in the morning with kind
of like one eye
looking at my phone,
I don't get a bunch
of work emails.
I switch that back
on when I'm ready.
And other people switch that off
at weekends and other things.
Because we know, now because
we've got this profile,
we know what are work apps
and what aren't because, well,
your work apps are in your
work side of your phone.
You can to switch
that work side off.
And actually, the
interesting thing-- it
doesn't work quite
like this animation.
So when you switch it back on,
because the cryptographic key
has been thrown away, it will
actually ask you for your pin
again because, again, it
has to log in to that phone.
So you've got the kind of work
profile switch, on and off.
That's one digital
well-being thing.
We've added the ability
to let you see how
to spend time on your device.
By giving user's data,
we can help them become
more aware of their habits.
Yeah, often what
happens, to me at least,
is I get a notification
that an email comes in.
So I open my phone up
to respond to that.
And then I get another
notification from social media.
And before I know it, I've
spent 10 minutes scrolling up
social media, and
I've completely
forgotten why I unlocked that
device in the first place.
So we want to make sure that the
time you spend on your device
is high-quality time by giving
you visibility and providing
controls.
So first, in terms
of awareness, we've
introduced a dashboard
which gives you
snapshots of your digital
habits with three metrics.
So you've got your
screen time, so
how you spend that, which apps
you are in the most, and so on,
and then how many times
you've unlocked your phone.
Often, we don't realize
actually how much
time, how often we
do that in a day,
and how many notifications
you receive, so which apps
are distracting you the most.
So on the left here, you'll
see how your day breaks down
on what you spend your time on.
And if you tap for
further information,
you can see trends over time.
And this is especially
useful if you're
trying to change your habits.
You can actually
see, well, you know,
am I actually changing my habits
by looking at these trends?
And for the apps that you
want to be mindful of,
we've introduced app timers.
And so once you've
used the amount of time
you've allotted
for that, the app
will gray-out and will be
paused for the rest of the day.
And you won't get a
notifications from that app
either.
So we've all experienced how
distracting these devices
can be.
Sitting down in a meeting,
getting a notification,
often that happens
to several people
in the meeting and,
of course, the devices
in this case interacting
with us when we actually
don't want it to.
We don't want to be distracted.
We're in a meeting.
And so we've
introduced gestures.
One of them is Flip to Shhh.
So if you flip your phone
over, it won't distract you.
It won't make any
notification sounds or ring
if there are incoming calls.
So this is on the
latest pixel devices
and a number of other
devices from various OEMs.
The other feature we've
introduced is Wind Down.
So lack of sleep
caused a $400 billion
productivity hit to
companies in the US
in 2016, according to a study.
And for many people in this
room, that's tens of millions
of dollars.
So, and we sort of realized
that getting pinged at 11:00
PM probably isn't
helping with that.
And because sleep
is really important
and can keep us
from getting enough,
we've introduced this
Wind Down feature.
So Wind Down sets a
schedule to remind you
when to switch off at night.
So you set a bedtime
for your phone,
and it fades to grayscale and
sets itself to Do Not Disturb.
So it will silence
notifications.
It's still completely usable
and allows you to finish up
whatever you were doing.
But our studies are showing
that it's a lot less
engaging and distracting.
So it's much harder to
get stuck in that sort
of infinite scroll or a video.
So that's a important part
of our well-being story.
It's early days,
and Android will
continue to invest in
digital well-being,
both from a consumer and
enterprise perspective.
Users tell us that
these types of features
are helping them
to change behavior,
and it's a real opportunity
for IT departments
to champion these things
and raise awareness
with their employees.
So we'll continue to
invest in well-being
for consumer and enterprise.
Something that we're
working on actively
right now is in-app switching.
So if you were,
for example, using
Gmail in your personal profile
and you want to change accounts
to your work profile to
reply to emails there,
you can do that
from within the app,
and it will actually
sort of seamlessly
switch out the personal and
work version of the app.
So we're working on that.
We'll continue to invest
in Android as a platform.
You may or may not know,
but Android is actually
a very popular choice for
line-of-business applications,
so things like kiosks, or
digital signage, point of sale,
rugged devices.
So in this sense, Android is
both flexible and powerful.
And we'll continue to
invest in these things
on this slide and more.
So hopefully, this
has given you a feel
for where Android
is going and why
Android is a great, great choice
for the needs of workers in IT.
And we hope that you've
seen how Android devices can
be both secure and respectful
and is showing how IT needs,
business needs, and
needs of employees
can, will be, aligned.
[MUSIC PLAYING]